j'invite les honorables députés de se
lever on entend toute l'horreur
l'incompréhension la tristesse
une douleur profonde ressentie jusque
dans l'enceinte du Parlement et nous
sommes tous de tout cœur avec les
familles touchées par cette tragédie
insensée comme père de famille je peux
imaginer la souffrance des familles
affectées et nous offrons tous nos
supports et nos prières pour les
familles là nos enfants que nous avons
de plus précieux et ce qui est survenu
ce matin nous glace le sang nous sommes
tous sur le choc une vague de sympathie
qui secoue les cœurs peu importe la
couleur politique c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne pourrait pas imaginer c'est une
tragédie vraiment horrible c'est une
situation qui évidemment nous bouleverse
tous
personne qui était l'abri d'une tragédie
semblable mais ça fait vraiment mal et
nos pensées accompagnent les victimes et
des familles des victimes je n'ai pas
les mots pour exprimer comment c'était
horrible beaucoup de compassion beaucoup
d'empathie pour les gens de Laval en
général mais singulièrement pour les
familles il n'y a rien de plus
précieux dans nos coeurs à tous que les
enfants en matinée l'information filtrée
au compte-goutte l'incertitude et le
désarroi gagnaient les députés du coin
je vous remercie la service policière un
mot de reconnaissance pour les premiers
répondants et une main tendue pour la
communauté touchée nous serons là pour
offrir toi tout à l'appui qu'on peut un
moment de recueillement pour les enfants
perdus et pour les parents qui n'auront
pas de calais ce soir ici Christian Noël
Radio-Canada
Ottawa